[Music]
line three is bill in philadelphia hi
bill welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave hi chris good talking to you
guys you too sir what's up
um so i'm a little nervous
right now because um i just turned 36
years old
and i'm 162 000 debt
and i just got engaged
congratulations thank you uh
what's the debt what kind of debt it's
all student loan debt are you a doctor
or a lawyer
i'm actually an architect which
unfortunately
is not a doctor or lawyer in terms of a
salary
well it can you can create an excellent
income though
how long you've been practicing um so i
have been licensed for two years but
i've been practicing for seven
okay good well you just at the beginning
stages of your career what's your
what's your income uh so
uh right now i'm i'm bringing in
70 growths
but it's like upper
40s 50 lower 50s than that
no you got a bunch of crap coming out
your check if that's the case you don't
have 20 000 taxes coming out on 70.
but yeah i'm not really yeah you should
be
you should be moving up the ladder
towards 100 pretty quick though
is that the trajectory you're on with
your firm are you going to be looking
so one of the one of the big things
pretty much
one of the main things i wanted to ask
you about is
starting a family well while being in
debt um
if that's a concern if should i pay off
the student loan first and
and part of that is my fiance
got a job in uh across the country in
portland
in portland yeah so where are y'all
so you're leaving there you're going to
move to portland yeah
and uh so what does she make
so currently she makes about 50.
um so why does a 50 000 job decide where
the 70 000
job lives i don't understand well she's
gonna be making
uh 110. win
um and it's a big career move for her
i'm i'm very proud of her
um no but when does the 110 happen
january okay okay all right well then
you go to portland be an architect and
you're going to have a 200 000
household income awesome
how much debt does she have okay so to
answer
let me answer your question bill before
we just keep popping at you here
uh we do not tell people to not get
married because of debt
and we do not tell people to not start
families because of debt
uh you have to be thoughtful and wise
meaning i wouldn't recommend having 16
children while you have 160 000
in debt but to have the first child or
the second child or whatever while you
while you're fighting your way through
160 000 worth of debt
making 200 000 a year is very doable
and we don't you know we let god help
you decide
about babies and marriages and you do
those things when you're supposed to do
them no
i do not tell people to be out of debt
before they're married and no we do not
tell people to
wait to have children before they're
until they're out of debt yeah
okay okay okay so here's here's what's
happening
getting married and moving and having
babies
is all coming at you really really fast
and you suddenly woke up and went
oh crap yeah
yeah you hit the fast forward button
buddy
on a lot of stuff yeah and it just it
just because you had 162 000 six months
ago
yep but you hadn't thought nothing about
it i i
i mean i i i'm honestly feeling very
stressed out because yeah i can hear
your voice
i actually sat down and looked at it you
know
i only borrowed 111.
so you know let's play them out let's
play a math game for a second okay
the average household income in america
is 59 000
all right so if you live at or
below average that frees up a hundred
thousand dollars a year when you're
making 200
and you take 60 out in some taxes okay
and if you take 100 a year and put it on
162
is that two years where you come from
i'm sorry sick okay all right let's try
again
you're working and making 90 in portland
she's making 110
that's 200 000 income this is my
projection for you
okay okay you have 162 000 in debt
the average household income in america
is 60.
60 from 200 leaves 140 you following me
okay so you live on an average income
not a jacked up 200 000
lifestyle in freaking portland oregon
okay you just calm your little butt down
and you live on beans and rice
rice and beans and you live on 60 000 a
year that leaves you 140. we'll set 40
aside for taxes
and that leaves a hundred to throw at
the debt per year does that sound right
to you
yeah that does sound right and in two
years you're done in two years you're
down
yeah you're gonna be okay brother
all right unless you go over and sit on
your hands and go buy three cars
and a house you can't afford and that's
what
bill that's the thing i was going to
tell you there are some things you
should not do
going out there and trying to buy a home
right that is not the time
this is not the time thinking back and
slipping and thinking well
because we're gonna have a kid we need
an suv so i need to go out and get a
no yeah okay so you want to have
realistic conversations and set yourself
up for
for success dave i'll tell you another
thing to talk about is
hey if we do have a kid new wife what's
your plan
yeah are you planning to work or are you
planning to be at home
because if she's planning to be at home
now you you've got a budget off of just
your income
yeah we got to have these conversations
before you know you know
got some work to do here yes got some
work to do but you're going to be okay
bill i hear that
and i hope buddy you've got some real
good friends around you
that you can talk to or go talk to your
pastor about your stress
but make sure you're talking to your
wife about your feelings let that out